in Kent the roads lead to the ferry
ports the link to European freight so
this is a County familiar with the
rumble of lorries and the truck drivers
dread these roads becoming jammed that's
what happened three years ago when
strikes in France cause 30-mile
tailbacks on this side of the channel
now growing concerns that are No Deal
brexit could cause a recurrence so the
government wants to test a plan on
Monday morning around 150 lorries will
be brought here to the disused Manston
air-filled to see if it might be used as
an emergency lorry park
it'll be a brexit rehearsal but local
hall is a dubious it's a good idea that
it is is being done I think what will
show are the weaknesses within it the
road between the airport Madison and
between and down to Dover
are very narrow there are single lane in
many places and the complication for
vehicles and travelling in both
directions to get to and from the
airport will prove that it will be
something that will not be workable
especially when you have the large
volumes of traffic that they are
expecting should the worst-case scenario
happen just down the road more brexit
preparations Ramsgate Harbor being
dredged for possible use by Seabourn
Freight a shipping company with a
government contract but no ships so far
what we do definitely have is
nervousness the car industry fears
disruption - it's crucial supply chain
this company specializes in transporting
car parts between Europe and the UK
they're having to prepare for the
effects of brexit because in the
automotive world delays are very
expensive one of our automotive
customers if when the production stops
they are talking about 32,000 pound a
minute so you can imagine the cost
implement of the production line
stopping for a couple of hours you know
how much that would really cost we're
talking millions in half a day so here's
their answer the companies bought a
helicopter that can distribute crucial
parts if they're at risk of being held
up at the border there are less than
three months to go until brexit the
planning is becoming ever more intense
Adam Parsons Sky News Kent